when the stars were right they could
plunge from world to world through the
sky but when the stars were wrong they
could not live but although they no
longer live they would never really die
the all lay in stone houses in the great
city of our Lea preserved by the spells
of mighty Cthulhu for a glorious
resurrection when the Stars and the
earth might once more be ready for them
but at that time some force from outside
must serve to liberate their bodies my
Francis Whalen Thurston hey guys what's
up it's been a while since we covered
anything about Cthulhu and I know that
we have been jumping from guide you to
extinct creatures to even transformers
and starships but these strange and
weird fictional and extinct content are
our passion so the last video we made
about Lovecraftian monsters was what if
Cotulla was in the monster verse and if
you haven't seen it then I probably
suggest that you watch it after this
video but before that we also covered
the topic about who are the ancestors of
the great old one Cthulhu so it is only
natural that we follow up with who are
the children and offsprings of Cthulhu
the next generation of gods and old ones
but before you continue with the video
do you like share and subscribe for more
of these and there are as many as 80
other videos in our channel so check
that out oh yes master notification
valve for regular updates anyway here
are the children of Cthulhu the
offsprings and spawns but let's explain
a bit about Cthulhu before going to the
list Cthulhu is a great old one of great
power that lies in a deathlike slumber
beneath the Pacific Ocean in a sunken
city of our Lea
according to love graph humans can never
fully understand Cthulhu because his
very existence is beyond mortal
comprehension love crass universe
contains many creatures that are equally
incomprehensible Cthulhu came from the
stars and millions of years ago waged
war with the other things and the Elder
Gods but for some mysterious reason
decided to take a deathlike nap under
the ocean
has had quite a few offsprings back in
his day mm-hmm and here are the ones
known to us number one the Leviathan
asked by the extract from the
Necronomicon it is also called as a
stellar lava an offspring of death
Leviathan has seen fear and worship and
named by men it is linked by its dreams
to the one who sleeps and will not rest
until his divine progenitor is free
there's no greater predator on earth and
yet the being that feeds on huge
creatures will never directly attack men
okay so the Leviathan is a name given by
some intimate cultures to a child of
Cthulhu but it is not clear if it is the
one of the name sons although it also
seems that likely that Leviathan is
identical to behemoth number two Nick
Tolu who one of the twin daughters of
Cthulhu and along with Nick Tosa they
are called the twin dollars and spawn of
Cthulhu they are currently imprisoned in
the great red spot on the planet Jupiter
they both appear as huge shell and out
beings with eight segmented limbs and
six long arms ending with claws vaguely
resembling their half-sister Katella
the sisters barely had any contact with
their stepsister Cthulhu but it can be
assumed that they are on good terms
Nick talu bears many striking
similarities to her sister however like
her she also inherited her father's
shape-shifting abilities but it is
limited to forms not unlike those that
are familiar upon earth she is capable
of taking various aquatic shapes and
forms since she is a lessor old one but
even though she is a lesser old one her
powers and abilities are so powerful
that humans cannot comprehend the limits
of what she can do number three Nick
dosa Nick dosa is another one of the
twin spawn of Cthulhu whom was born from
the union of the slumbering God and his
sister turn mate
the doctor Nick dosa inherited her
father's ability to shape-shift
however due to her being a lesser o'lone
her shape-shifting ability is pale in
comparison to those of greater all ones
these transformations include various
appearances of aquatic marine life have
been in rather horrendous shapes and
forms
while Nick dosa is able to assume any
form her true form consists of her being
a huge shell in doubt being with 8
segmented limbs and six long arms ending
with claws this form is also attributed
to her twin sister
Nick Telugu Nita Liu and Nick dosa are
currently in prison in the great red
spot upon the planet Jupiter for reasons
unknown it is highly likely that one of
the elder gods imprison them there
seeing as that despite their status as
lesser old ones are incredibly
destructive and can bring about the
madness and plague that their father
will spread when he awakens from our Lea
so both of these twin daughters of
Cthulhu are devoted to their fathers
plans and await his return from his
dreamlike state number four teeth
nothing much is known about this child
of Cthulhu except for the fact that he
death is the offspring of the great old
one Cthulhu and the elder god zip tie we
tried researching about this offspring
but we could not find anything about him
or his mother the other God but it seems
rather peculiar that Cthulhu had a
relationship with one of the l a-- gods
given the fact that they were at war for
a very long time and in the end was
banished to earth by them number five
zot amok zot amok is a great old one and
the third son of Cthulhu featured in
exotic legend cycle by Lin Carter he has
a cone-shaped body a razor fang
reptilian head rather like that of a
Tyrannosaurus Rex for brought flat
starfish like arms with suckers and a
mane of tentacles how he swims our walks
on the ocean floors are known but it is
possible that he has a slug like foot
similar to doubt of the great race of
Earth Jaffa mop was imprisoned by the
elder gods beneath the seabed
near Pune per and R'lyeh like its older
brother is dr. Zama is served by Father
OOP and yolks of almost legend is
chronicled in their earlier tags and
eponymous Scripture
number six your doctor your doctor also
known as the thing in the pit is a great
old one who appears in HP Lovecraft
inspired Cthulhu Mythos spawn my Cthulhu
and idea on the distant planet zot
doctor was brother to gotten a Toa
Zod amok and Katella though like all of
the great old ones he is similar to
nothing else that exists in thathe is
the second son of Cthulhu and resembles
a gigantic humanoid frog or a deep one
with only a single huge eye in the
center of his forehead like a cyclops a
dense mane and a beer of rything
tentacles grows from its head Yatta is
incredibly large when the sorcerer
priests xantho attempts to free a
thoughtful from his prison he mistakes
the gods Claude slimy fingertips for
mountainous heads the Elder Gods
imprison your thoughts in the abyss of
year he is served by the planarian like
nukes and a lot OOP the father of the
worms number seven got in a Thor
gardener Sawa the dark God is a great
old one and the first born of Cthulhu
spawned by a Thea on a Planet zob it is
a huge amorphous monstrosity whose
appearance is so hideous than anyone who
gazes upon it or even a perfect replica
of it it's petrified into a living mummy
the victim is permanently immobilized
the body taking on the consistency of
leather and the internal organs and
brain preserved indefinitely yet remains
fully aware only the destruction of the
subjects brain or the application of a
magic scroll can free it from its
hellish prison though the unfortunate is
likely to be incurably insane long
before the welcome released spawn my
castle and Athiya on a Planet zob
guarana Thor was brought to earth by an
ancient alien race possibly the me Oh
millennia ago who then entombed it
beneath the moon yeah let's go on the
lost continent of MU which lies at a
bottom of the Pacific Ocean in modern
times number 8 Casilla Casilla also
known as the Kraken or the secret one is
an offspring of Cthulhu and Athiya and
the door of Cthulhu and as critical to
his plans as should Cthulhu somehow die
Katella will give birth to him once more
as such she is guarded by the Deep Ones
and Yuya in what might be assumed to be
our Lea as she was first born from the
stars earth but later on came to earth
Katella is a great old one and is the
youngest progeny of Cthulhu and his
androgynous mates
nidia Katella has the appearance of a
gigantic red body black ringeth and
six-eyed octopus with small wings like a
father he is able to alter her body
proportions at will such as by enlarging
her wings to enable her to fly while she
normally has eight arms like any octopus
she can extrude or retract additional
ones at will and number nine the Cthulhu
also known as a star spawn of Cthulhu
and they are sapiens species that have a
similar appearance to degree old one
Cthulhu but are far smaller sizes
relatively little is known about the
Cthulhu other than that they arrived on
earth with tulu and are his underlings
after coming to earth the star spawns
built a great basalt city called our
Leah on an island in the Pacific Ocean
murals and scriptures and sculptures
preserved beneath the alien ruins in the
Antarctic record a war that they wage
against the other things after arriving
on earth but thereafter established a
treaty this treaty gave the Katori
dominion over most of Earth's landmasses
while the other things would largely
retreat the disease although they still
occupied settlements like those fall in
Antarctica initially described as a land
race of beings shaped like octopi and
probably corresponding to the fabulous
pre-human spawn of Cthulhu the star
spawn are also described as being
composed of matter more widely different
than that which is native to our
universe and with that we now come to
the end of the list of offsprings of
Cthulhu which we included both his
children and his pawns
so now along with the video about the
ancestors with Cthulhu we have the
complete family tree of Cthulhu
but we still have more to cover about
Lovecraft in Monster so do like share
subscribe for more related videos like
these and smash a notification bar for
regular updates